I'm Laura Ingram this is Ingram angle
from Washington tonight we have breaking
news on multiple stories stunning scenes
out of Eagle Pass Texas tonight as the
Lone Star State takes a stand for its
own sovereignty and the rule of law by
blocking the Biden Welcome Wagon from
fast-tracking migrants into the United
States and in Chicago they were forced
to move thousands of migrants into what
they're calling warming buses due to the
record cold temperatures hitting that
Reg
and moving East to Massachusetts a group
in Melrose called The Immigrant support
Alliance is reportedly encouraging
residents to open their homes to the
migrants an information session there
called exploring the host home
experience takes place on Monday and the
notice reads are you curious about
what's involved in hosting an immigrant
for short-term shelter as they begin
their journey toward
Independence today housing immigrants in
your house is voluntary but tomorrow
we'll see and at a time when the country
is struggling to cope with and pay for
the millions that Biden's already waved
in most of them from third world
countries draft legislation being
supported by Chuck Schumer and Mitch
McConnell will make it even easier for
Biden to Greenlight almost 2 million
more over the next year alone now I
asked the ranking member of the Senate
Homeland Security committee about it
earlier this week this border deal that
the Republicans are cooking up that
Chuck Schumer and apparently Mitch
McConnell and others are going to agree
to to that you say it's a sellout it's
going to continue to allow illegal
immigration particularly migrants it's
saying oh we'll let 5,000 people come
illegally a day and then after that we
might try to stop the next 5,000 that
day it's completely a sellout but it's
because people like Senator McConnell
care more about Ukraine than anything
else I would say that this is the most
important piece of legislation that will
be considered this year perhaps in The
Last 5 Years and yet it's tangled up
with another $60 billion spending
request for Ukraine now this is the
first sign it's bad and Oklahoma senator
Jim Langford on the border subcommittee
is spearheading this bill and it's
supported by the most Notorious BIG
spending open borders
Republicans this shouldn't be something
that we don't address here how can we
address this in a bipartisan way
unfortunately the house didn't have any
Democrats on board and for the last two
and a half months we've met in a
bipartisan way to hammer out how do we
solve this Senator lford you've done an
extraordinary job of
negotiating um what I think is going to
be a successful compromise that's going
to get support from Republicans and
Democrats yeah says Tom Tillis the man
who voted to give Biden a trillion
dollars for infrastructure which ended
up being a gateway to an even worse
so-called inflation reduction act while
details in this border Bill are already
leaking out and they usually remember
like doing these types of things
releasing the text of a bill in the
middle of the night they bury the damage
and hundreds or thousands of pages of
text that is almost always written by
lobbyist but tonight we seem to know
this that anything Schumer and Durban
will agree to will be a shiv in the back
of American workers and a gift to Big
Business and Biden's campaign why do it
the legislation will reportedly increase
the number of foreign workers allowed in
the country give immediate work permits
to those released from custody and still
allows several thousand more migrants
every day to enter more on this in a
moment with Mike Lee now it's worth
noting that when he was up for
re-election in 2022 Senator Langford
sounded pretty tough on the Biden border
Fiasco he was hitting Biden's decision
to Simply process people into the
country more quickly and at the time he
noted that the National Security crisis
they've created for the country and the
chaos they've created at the border that
Langford was right someone should go try
to find him now look no further than his
bed fellows and the house who are
parting their tired old arguments we
need immigrants in this
country forget the fact that
the farm that are are are vegetables
would rot in the ground if it weren't if
they weren't being picked by many
immigrants many illegal
immigrants do you ever remember not
having vegetables growing
up neither do I now no Republican should
touch this or be involved with this Sham
in any way shape or form let the voters
sort this out in November we don't need
a big leaf of enforcement we need a new
president now McConnell even admitted
behind closed doors that they're afraid
that Trump won't cave and give them the
foreign workers they want read between
the lines there now it might make sense
that Democrats would want to import more
workers into the United States right
because they're the party of woke Wall
Street and the
plutocracy but it makes no sense that
Republicans who are winning right now
because of the votes of working people
and who by the way are despised by Big
Business it makes no sense for them to
help the left at every turn hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else